ich rufe auf den soeben aufgesetzten
Zusatzpunkt 7 Beschlussempfehlung des
Vermittlungsausschusses auf Drucksache
4600 zu dem Gesetz zur Änderung des
zweiten Buches Sozialgesetzbuch und
anderer Gesetze Einführung eines
Bürgergeldes
Berichterstatterin im Bundestag ist die
Abgeordnete Katja Mast Berichterstatter
im Bundesrat ist Ministerpräsident Boris
rein als Berichterstatterin des
Bundestages hat Abgeordnete Katja Mast
eine Protokollerklärung des der
Bundesregierung zu Protokoll gegeben
der Bundesregierung her im
Vermittlungsausschuss so ist es richtig
mir wurde mitgeteilt dass das Wort für
Erklärungen nach § 10 Absatz 2 der
geschäftsordnungsvermittlungsausschusses
gewünscht wird das Wort hat zuerst für
die SPD-Fraktion Dagmar Schmidt
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich freue mich
heute das Ergebnis des
Vermittlungsausschusses für meine
Fraktion bewerten zu dürfen denn für die
SPD-Fraktion ist heute ein wirklich
schöner Tag
und zunächst einmal möchte ich
[Applaus]
dafür dass wir ein tolles Gesetz hier im
Bundestag beschlossen haben und danke an
Hubertus Heil und das Ministerium dafür
dass Sie viel Zeit und Kraft in das
Gesetz aber auch in die Einigung im
Vermittlungsausschuss und mit dem
Bundesrat investiert haben und ich
möchte mich ganz ausdrücklich bedanken
bei den unionsgeführten Ländern vorneweg
Herr Minister Laumann die eine sachliche
Diskussion über das Bürgergeld
ermöglicht haben trotz der Debatten der
letzten Wochen denn ob wir zur Mehrheit
im Bundestag auch eine Mehrheit im
Bundesrat bekommen das war nicht sicher
aber gerade in Zeiten wie diesen ist es
wichtig dass DemokratInnen und
Demokraten Kompromisse finden statt sich
zu blockieren das ist gelungen dafür
allen Beteiligten der Ampel und der
Union ein großes Dankeschön
heute ist für uns ein guter Tag weil wir
Hartz IV hinter uns lassen ich habe in
den letzten Tagen der Gespräche um das
Bürgergeld mal wieder unser
sozialstaatskonzept von vor drei Jahren
in die Hand genommen wir haben darin
aufgeschrieben was wir für die Menschen
die arbeiten tun wollen unter anderem
ein Mindestlohn von 12 Euro haben wir
schon eine Kindergrundsicherung kommt
noch mehr Tarifbindung und Mitbestimmung
vieles andere mehr was wir auf der
Agenda haben und wir haben
aufgeschrieben was wir für die Menschen
machen wollen die arbeiten wollen aber
nicht können Sie wollen wir stärken ihn
mehr Respekt entgegenbringen ihn mehr
Rechte mehr Schutz und mehr Möglichkeit
geben und alles das erreichen wir heute
mit dem Bürgergeld
uns geht es mit der umstrittenen
Karenzzeit gerade um diejenigen die
schon viel geleistet haben die ihren Job
verloren haben und die nicht schnell
wieder einen neuen finden weil sie
vielleicht schon älter sind oder länger
krank oder Selbstständige die keinen
Schutz durch die
Arbeitslosenversicherung haben der
vorübergehende Bezug des Bürgergeldes
wirkt sich nun nicht sofort auf die
Wohnung oder das Ersparte aus leider nur
ein statt zwei Jahre aber das ist
trotzdem ein guter Schutz der vielen
hilft
und mit denen die schon lange draußen
sind oder die es aus der Bahn geworfen
hat sind wir bereit auch einen längeren
Weg zu gehen und wir haben für diesen
Weg mit dem kooperationsplan und einem
Schlichtungsverfahren die
Arbeitssuchenden mit ihren Vorstellungen
gestärkt der Gedanke der
Partnerschaftlichkeit steht im Zentrum
der Zusammenarbeit zwischen Jobcenter
und Arbeitssuchenden und dazu haben wir
die Möglichkeiten für eine passgenaue
Unterstützung ausgeweitet die
Möglichkeit einer dreijährigen
Ausbildung die Ausweitung des sozialen
Arbeitsmarktes ein weiterbildungsbonus
Coaching und vieles andere mehr hier
findet der Kulturwandel statt nicht mehr
schnelle Vermittlungen in irgendeinen
Job sondern nachhaltige Vermittlung in
einen guten Job und Zusammenarbeit auf
Augenhöhe das ist der Paradigmenwechsel
kommen Sie bitte zum Schluss ich möchte
mit einem Zitat von Helmut Schmidt die
Demokratie lebt vom Kompromiss wer keine
Kompromisse machen kann ist für die
Demokratie nicht zu gebrauchen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir haben einen
guten Kompromiss ich bitte um ihre
Zustimmung
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Hermann Gröhe
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen liebe
Kollegen die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion stimmt dem
Ergebnis des Vermittlungsausschusses zu
wir stimmen zu weil dieses Ergebnis das
Gesetz dass wir in diesem Hause vor zwei
Wochen abgelehnt haben in ganz
grundsätzlicher Weise verändert und es
ist ja bemerkenswert es ist ja
bemerkenswert dass in den letzten Tagen
an diesem Gesetz vor allen Dingen Dinge
gelobt werden vom Hinzuverdienst bis zu
den Regelsätzen die eins gemeinsam haben
sie sind von uns im
Gesetzgebungsverfahren zu keinen
Zeitpunkt kritisiert worden kritisiert
hat die Union in diesem Hause haben die
arbeitsministerinnen und Arbeitsminister
aus den rein der Union in den
Bundesländern
grundsätzliche Webfehler die die Balance
von fördern und fördern betreffen die
die Nachrangigkeit einer steuerlich
finanzierten Sozialleistung gegenüber
der Inanspruchnahme eines nicht
unerheblichen eigenen Vermögens und hier
verändert der Vermittlungsausschuss das
Ergebnis der bundestagsberatung ganz
grundsätzlich
ich nenne das Beispiel der sogenannten
vertrauenszeit sie wird eben nicht
verändert sie wird eben nicht verkürzt
sie wird abgeschafft und sie selbst
haben diese vertrauenszeit als ein
wesentliches Element ihrer Reform
bezeichnet sie wird abgeschafft die
Praktiker in den Jobcentern sagen gut so
und wir verändern die
Karenzzeit wir verändern da die Grenzen
für die in Anspruchnahme eigenen
Vermögens das stärkt die Fairness in
unserem Sozialstaat meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren ich glaube das ist ein
gutes Ergebnis 74% der Bevölkerung
teilen die Auffassung dass diese
Korrektur notwendig und richtig war wir
wünschen dass die Instrumente dieses
Gesetzes jetzt genutzt werden deswegen
bedauern wir es dass die Ampel die
Chance dieser haushaltswoche ungenutzt
hat verstreichen lassen unsere Jobcenter
besser auszustatten um dieser Arbeit
gerecht werden zu können meine Damen
meine Herren
ob wir Hartz IV überwinden
entscheidet sich nicht an der
Umbenennung einer Sozialleistung sondern
daran ob es uns gelingt mehr Menschen in
Arbeit zu vermitteln darum muss es gehen
und ich möchte von dieser Stelle aus
auch die Wirtschaft auffordern die
Möglichkeiten etwa das von uns
geschaffenen und jetzt infristeten
sozialen Arbeitsmarktes zu nutzen
Menschen auch durch den Anspruchnahme
von lohnzuschüssen Teilhabe auf Arbeit
zu ermöglichen dieser Kompromiss trägt
die Handschrift der Unionsfraktion
deswegen stimmen wir gerne zu
nächste Rednerin für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen Britta Hasselmann
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren ich begründe kurz warum
ich dem vermittlungsergebnis zugestimmt
habe und meine Fraktion die es gleich
auch tun wird nämlich dass es Sinn der
Aussprache wenn es überhaupt eine gibt
zu dem Punkt
annahmevermittlungsergebnis es geht auch
nicht darum ob irgendwer irgendeine
Handschrift hat oder nicht es geht um
die Menschen im Land und um die
Unterstützung der Menschen
die Ermutigung und Hilfe benötigen meine
Damen und Herren das Bürgergeld kommt
und mit ihm die Regelsatzerhöhung das
ist gut und wichtig und das ist das
Mindeste was wir in dieser
Krisensituation tun können darüber
hinaus wird es seinen Vorrang
weiter
Bildung geben der vermittlungsvorgang
fällt und das ist ein ganz wichtiges
Signal für die Menschen denn der
drehtüreffekt den viele Betroffene
erlebt haben in der Vergangenheit
endet damit es geht nicht mehr darum
Menschen einfach in irgendwas zu
vermitteln und dann in ein paar Monaten
sie wieder im Jobcenter zu haben sondern
jetzt sind Qualifizierung und
Weiterbildung ein ganz klarer und
wichtiger Akzent dieser bürgergeldreform
und das ist wichtig und richtig und
deshalb gut so
ein zweiter Punkt ist die
vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit auch hier
gibt es einen klaren Vorgang und das ist
eine klare Veränderung zur alten ALG2
Gesetzgebung sie ist bedeutend für alle
Menschen die Hilfe und Unterstützung in
Anspruch nehmen denn das heißt Beratung
und Coaching und alles was im Jobcenter
für Menschen die Unterstützung und
Beratung brauchen läuft auf Augenhöhe
und das hat dieses Gesetz noch mal klar
zum Ausdruck gebracht das ist wichtig
und gut so der dritte Punkt es gibt
einen klaren Vorrang für Kooperation der
ist festgeschrieben durch einen
kooperationsplan durch einen
schlichtungsmechanismus darüber hinaus
gibt es
Hinzuverdienstmöglichkeiten ich glaube
dass mit diesem Gesetz ein groß Schritt
getan ist wirklich jetzt eine
Sozialreform auf den Weg zu bringen die
auf Ermutigung und Unterstützung setzt
und das ist für die betroffenen Menschen
im Land ganz bedeutend und da geht es
nicht im Kleinklein darum wir irgendeine
Handschrift irgendwo hingesetzt hat
meine Damen und Herren und lassen sie
mich zum Schluss noch sagen ich fand die
Debatte im Vermittlungsausschuss sehr
sachorientiert es gab keine Polemik es
gab keine soziale Spaltung es gab keine
Diffamierung von Menschen die in Not und
Armut leben und eine Spaltung in die die
Arbeit haben und die die keiner haben
und die Methode Populismus hatte im
Vermittlungsausschuss und empfinden
dieses Ergebnisses überhaupt keinen Raum
das war gut so meine Damen und Herren
und ich habe nicht
hat gefragt ob es daran liegt dass
Friedrich Merz und Markus Söder nicht
dabei waren danke
nächster Redner für die FDP-Fraktion
Johannes Vogel
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin lieber Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
das in unserer Demokratie sich ein
Gesetz weiterentwickelt nach einem
ersten Entwurf des zuständigen Ministers
dann nach Beratung in der Koalition und
dann wenn unsere Verfassung das vorsieht
auch in einem Vermittlungsverfahren das
ist ein ganz normales demokratisches
Verfahren und wir haben als Koalition
von Anfang an gesagt Anspruch muss sein
in der Sache zu diskutieren und ein
gutes Gesetz noch besser zu machen und
das ist gelungen mit dem Vorschlag der
heute hier vorliegt und deswegen werde
ich als Mitglied des
Vermittlungsausschusses und meine
Fraktion gleich auch zustimmen und ich
will kurz erläutern warum erstens klar
war und ist Fördern und Fordern gilt
auch beim Bürgergeld und ist gut dass
das jetzt unmissverständlich auch für
jeden in diesem Land klar ist meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
klar ist auch dass die Grundsicherung
enorm reformbedürftig war wir mussten
sie doch moderner und unbürokratischer
machen wir gaben 60 Millionen Euro aus
jedes Jahr um 18 Millionen Euro Cent
Beträge wieder einzutreiben Menschen
mussten am Anfang im Hartz IV-System
sich am Anfang wenn Sie in einer durch
einen Schicksalsschlag in eine
Lebenskrise kommen Details ihres
Mietvertrags diskutieren erspart es
aufbrauchen all das wird Bürgern beim
Bürgergeld nicht mehr zugemutet und das
ist eine gute Modernisierung der
Grundsicherung insbesondere können Sie
auch Ihre Altersvorsorge behalten weil
auch in Lebenskrisen wollen wir
Eigenverantwortung und Vorsorge
bestrafen und nicht belohnen und das
eine gute Modernisierung liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
aber
der Kern der Kern des Bürgergeldes ist
wirklich dass wir unsere Grundsicherung
fairer und
aufstiegsorientierter machen und das
sieht man übrigens auch an den Zahlen
von der Verbesserung der
zuverdienstregeln für die wir als Freie
Demokraten viele viele Jahre gekämpft
haben profitieren direkt über eine halbe
Million Menschen für die es leichter
wird sich Schritt für Schritt
rauszuarbeiten aus der
Hilfsbedürftigkeit eine Brücke zu
betreten wieder in die finanzielle
Selbstständigkeit und das muss doch der
Anspruch unseres Sozialstaat sein liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und ganz besonders wichtig ist das für
die 1,9 Millionen junge Menschen die
heute in sogenannten Hartz-IV-Familien
groß werden dass wir für die mehr
Fairness in diesem Land schaffen die
waren mich bisher in der Situation dass
ich ihre Ausbildung nicht lohnt weil sie
wenn sie eine Ausbildung machen von
ihrem Ausbildungsgehalt nur 200 Euro
behalten können rund beim Bürgergeld
werden es über 600 Euro sein so geht
Leistungsgerechtigkeit liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und
junge Menschen erfahren nicht mehr schon
am Anfang ihres Lebens beim ersten
selbst verdienten Geld dass ich ihre
Anstrengung weniger lohnt wegen der
Familie in die sie geboren wurden das
ist das Gegenteil von
Chancengerechtigkeit unabhängig von der
Herkunft und das schaffen wir endlich ab
in diesem Land liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen bisher musste man
bei der Grundsicherung zu oft
Chancengerechtigkeit im Dunkeln suchen
mit den Bürgergeld und den besseren
Zuverdienst Regeln schalten wir das
Licht an und das ist eine sehr gute
Nachricht für unser Land vielen Dank
[Applaus]
nächster Redner für die afd-fraktion DR
Götz Frömming
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren geschätzter Kollege frei ich muss
noch mal auf das eingehen was sie eben
sagten also es wundert uns ehrlich
gesagt nicht dass sie das Ergebnis
dieser kugelei hier verteidigen denn sie
haben ja selber mitgekuckt und und
übrigens ist das ja auch nicht das erste
Mal dass wir das Erleben schon während
der corona-pandemie vielen die
eigentlichen Entscheidungen eben nicht
in denen von der Verfassung dafür
vorgesehenen Gremien sondern in den
Runden zu den damals Frau Merkel die
Minister eingestellt hat so geht man
nicht mit unserer Verfassung rum um
meine Damen und Herren und wenn sie denn
schon nicht wenn sie denn schon nicht
die Kritik meines Kollegen Brandner
annehmen wollen vielleicht lesen Sie
heute mal den Kommentar der ARD dazu aus
dem hauptstadtbüro der Ardian heißt der
glaube ich der spricht genau das gleiche
aus was Kollege Brandner auch gesagt hat
die Union hat mit ihrem voreiligen aus
plaudern noch vor der prostituierung des
Ausschusses dem Ansehen unserer
demokratischen Ordnung geschadet
schreibt ein Journalist der ARD meine
Damen und Herren
zur Sache selbst um was geht es hier
denn eigentlich das wird jetzt so als
großer Erfolg verkauft die Wahrheit ist
doch die die Ampel wollte den Begriff
Hartz IV loswerden die Union hat dazu
die Hand gereicht und die Ampel hat
nahezu jedem Kompromiss hier mitgemacht
in Wahrheit haben wir hier keinen
Systemwechsel da kann die Union sich
selbst ein Stückchen auf die Schulter
feiern klopfen aber der Ampel ging es ja
auch gar nicht um einen Systemwechsel
ihnen ging es um einen etikettenwechsel
und das was wir alle gemeinsam
miteinander machen heute ist ein
Etikettenschwindel und da machen wir
nicht mit meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren
und ich kann ihnen eins prophezeien
diese Etikettenschwindel fliegen früher
oder später immer auf weil die Bürger
ist merken der Begriff Bürgergeld wird
in kurzer Zeit genauso verbrannt sein
wie der Begriff früher mal Asylant
verbrannt wurde wieder Begriff
Flüchtling verbrannt ist wieder Begriff
Fachkraft verbrannt wurde und so weiter
genauso wird der Begriff der Bürgergeld
auch verbrannt sein und schon heute
können sie ja lesen
[Applaus]
das aus den Kreisen der Union schon
kolportiert wird in Wirklichkeit ist das
nicht das Bürgergeld sondern Hartz 5
meine Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
zur Sache selbst haben Sie denn an den
wirklichen Problemen dieses Landes etwas
gelöst vielleicht lesen Sie mal was vor
kurzem anonym natürlich weil er sonst in
seinem Job fürchten müsste ein
Mitarbeiter in einem großen sogenannten
Jobcenter gesagt hat
die Mitarbeiter in den Jobcentern
frieren zu Hause mehr teilweise als die
Kunden die zu Ihnen kommen mit dem von
ihnen erzielten Kompromiss wird sich
nichts ändern an der Schieflage in
unserem Sozialsystem wir werden nicht
mehr Menschen in Arbeit bringen wir
werden nichts beseitigen an den
Ungerechtigkeiten sie haben nicht den
Magnet unseres Sozialstaates abgestellt
meine Damen und Herren sie haben von den
wahren großen Problemen dieses Landes
nichts gelöst sie sind das Problem
vielen Dank
nächste Rednerin für die Fraktion DIE
LINKE dr Gesine Lötzsch
hier in der amtsfrau-präsidentin meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren im
Vermittlungsausschuss wurde das Gesetz
nicht verbessert sondern verschlechtert
und darum hat die Linke mit Nein
gestimmt meine Damen und Herren Hermann
Gröhe von der CDU hat es ja geradezu
genüsslich ausgeführt die Ampel hat sich
von der Union bereitwillig über den
Tisch ziehen lassen Widerstand war nicht
zu erkennen das Bürgergeld ist eben
keine Überwindung von Hartz IV es ist
nur ein Täuschungsmanöver meine Damen
und Herren
wir als LINKE wollen Hartz IV
grundsätzlich überwinden die Erhöhung
des Regelsatzes um 53 Euro pro Monat ist
eben kein ausreichender
Inflationsausgleich allein die Preise
für die Grundnahrungsmittel sind in
einem Jahr über 20 Prozent gestiegen der
Paritätische Wohlfahrtsverband fordert
ein Regelsatz von 725 Euro im Monat eine
gute Forderung das Ziel der Linken ist
eine sanktionsfreie Mindestsicherung von
1.200 Euro
meine Damen und Herren auch bei der
Verschärfung der Sanktionen und der
Reduzierung des Schonvermögens hat die
Ampel sehr schnell eine Rolle rückwärts
gemacht so viel Einigkeit zwischen Ampel
und Union war selten und das finde ich
schlimm meine Damen und Herren
Kollegen Britta Hasselmann von den
Grünen hat nun erklärt dass das
Bürgergeld wie sie es vorgeschlagen
hätten im Kern erhalten geblieben wäre
das ist richtig denn der Kern des
Bürgergeldes heißt Hartz IV das ist die
Wahrheit meine Damen und Herren und
Hartz IV soll weiter als brokkulisse für
die Menschen aufrecht erhalten werden
die für niedrige Löhne arbeiten müssen
es ist doch nicht zu fassen dass in
unserem Land eine Million Menschen von
ihrem Lohn nicht leben können sie müssen
zum Amt gehen und aufstocken die
Arbeitgeber bezahlen die
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter zu
schlecht und die Steuerzahlerinnen und
Steuerzahler sind gezwungen die Löhne
aufzubessern das ist nicht zu
akzeptieren dass es würde los meine
Damen und Herren
11 Prozent der Nutzer der Tafel sind
Menschen die Vollzeit arbeiten das sagt
doch viel über den deutschen
Niedriglohnsektor aus der
Niedriglohnsektor muss beseitigt werden
meine Damen und Herren
und auch bei der Reduzierung von
Schonvermögen wurde nicht sachlich
diskutiert sondern ideologisch
Niedriglöhner sollten gegen Arbeitslose
aufgehetzt werden ich frage sie warum
gab es eigentlich nie eine Kampagne der
Union gegen Steuerhinterziehung das
spricht doch Bände meine Damen und
Herren
die Menschen in unserem Land werden
immer wieder aufgefordert für das Alter
Geld anzusparen weil die gesetzliche
Rente im nicht mehr ausreiche jetzt
vergreift man sich auch nach einem
Schonvermögen von Menschen die ihre
Arbeit verloren haben das ist schäbig
vor 20 Jahren haben wir Linken gegen
Hartz IV gestimmt weil es Armut per
Gesetz bedeutet wir brauchen endlich
einen wirklichen Systemwechsel das wäre
Würde und Respekt vielen Dank
wir kommen nun zur Abstimmung zur
Abstimmung liegen mehrere persönliche
Erklärungen nach Paragraph 31 unserer
Geschäftsordnung vor
wir stimmen ab gemäß Paragraph 10 Absatz
3 Satz 1 der Geschäftsordnung
über das Ergebnis dass der
vermittlungsausschluss beschlossen hat
wir stimmen nun über die
Beschlussempfehlung des
Vermittlungsausschusses auf Verlangen
der Fraktion der SPD Bündnis 90 die
Grünen FDP namentlich ab die Abstimmung
erfolgt in der westlobby sie haben zur
Abgabe ihrer Stimme nach Eröffnung der
Abstimmung 20 Minuten Zeit